savoir où à vélo éducation à la santé
savoir nager découvert du short tennis
ou encore du laser run de nouveaux
dispositifs proposés à
Vélizy-Villacoublay pour la 13ème
édition de la Journée nationale du sport
scolaire chaque année le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la Jeunesse
organise une grande fête pour promouvoir
le sport scolaire un événement basé sur
le thème de l'inclusion dans le sport le
thème de l'inclusion il est il est
fondamental puisque à l'UNSS on est on y
attire une importance particulière
puisqu'on a un programme qui s'appelle
le sport partagé où les élèves en
situation de handicap et quel que soit
leur handicap on a différentes
catégories cognitifs ou moteurs peuvent
s'engager dans la pratique avec des
élèves valides et former des équipes
pour aller jusqu'au championnat de
France les valeurs sont celles de
l'éducation nationale du vivre ensemble
du partage de l'inclusion de la santé et
elles font partie de l'UNSS puisque un
de nos leitmotiv c'est partageons plus
que du sport une matinée réservée à des
élèves de primaire les écoles et les
classes ont été sélectionnés par
l'inspecteur de l'Éducation nationale de
circonscription avec les directeurs
d'école les associations sportives des
collèges de Versailles Grand Port ont
aussi été accueillis aujourd'hui on a
fait du tennis et j'ai bien aimé parce
que j'en avais jamais fait on a aussi
fait un nouveau un nouveau sport que je
connaissais pas là-bas le ou on tire
avec un pistolet sur des cibles et après
en cours
c'était drôle et j'ai bien aimé ou m'a
fait une nouvelle épreuve que je
connaissais pas c'était en sorte de
Laser Game et ensuite qu'on avait marqué
à deux points on pouvait aller dans la
dans un fauteuil roulant mais c'était
très difficile c'est important de de
montrer aux jeunes que peu importe son
handicap on peut quand même faire des
rencontres faire du sport et on peut
adapter n'importe quelle forme de
pratique à ce à leur handicap et c'est
un des programmes et un des objectifs de
l'UNSS l'occasion aussi de lier sport à
la santé une étude de 2020 sur 15000
élèves de l'académie de Versailles
montre que 30% d'entre eux sont estimés
en mauvaise santé en France près de 2
millions d'élèves ont une licence
sportive